hello my name is pon pon and welcome to
the Xbox patch notes as you can see I am
NOT Scott Gandhi and you're welcome to
that so first things first coming to the
Xbox is some pc tech we already had with
a new camera angle on xbox right now
when you aim down it's a little bit hard
to see past characters like you me or
Khepri and with the new text on the pc
in the new camera angle when you're
aiming down are really close to you you
can actually see your target a lot more
clearly and hit things a lot easier also
in this path we have a huge buffer the
demon king of Lanka robin almost all of
us girls have been adjusted either up or
change make himself feel a little bit
better because one does more damage his
two does a little more damage his three
actually feels more and as ultimate is
now a new ability where you actually
targeted area you want to land deal
massive damage upon mine we also have a
huge remodel for nausea the third lotus
prints in this patch he has new
animations new particle effects and a
new model that match the current art
style Sony we also have a lot of skins
coming this patch we have see Jenna Jing
Tian we have the demon soul evansville
circuit which actually is a bundle and
the evidence that will only be available
for a limited time in this bundle and
after that we'll be going away the diva
Aphrodite and of course the opera singer
himself brynhilda Bacchus personal
favorite in this patrick also have a
whole host of achievements coming in for
a lot of God's most notably so Lanka
cokin the Cobra has dragons wrath which
is actually get a kill of his ultimate
any point in the game which is basically
get to late game and finally we have a
few small changes to crash most notably
we've added practice and co-op cues as
well as we removed the bait attacks with
classes officially out of beta on xbox
thanks so much for watching the xbox one
patch notes if you want you can head
over to Smike ENCOM to actually see more
detailed information on these path notes
or if you want to see more time just
xbox one smite click the annotation on
the screen
you